I know death
He's got many faces
I look forward to seeing this one
Everything you did brought you where you are now. Where you belong.
They're coming. Our enemy doesn't tire
Doesn't stop. Doesn't feel.
I promised to fight for the living
I intend to keep that promise.
Hey everybody its Charlie. We finally got our Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs buried in the backgrounds of a lot of these shots
So we'll break it down shot by shot
There's a new round of the book giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video
So first things first, we start with the Aria voiceover talking about the faceless men while she's running through the castle
So obviously they're mixing a lot of shots
the voiceover is coming from her looking at the dragon glass getting really excited about the army of the Dead like I'm not afraid I
Look forward to meeting deaths face when it arrives talking about the night King
But the shot of her running through the battlements is obviously from the actual battle during episode 3
So for the most part
I think all the footage that we see is just
Up to episode 3 the first half of the season because they alternate between shots of people arriving at Winterfell the golden company
Arriving at King's Landing Cersei meeting Euron and the leader of the golden company in the actual battle itself
Which is episode 3 and because they've been hyping it up so much
I think they're just focusing most of the trailer on that the tension before a lot of the interpersonal
politics that happen in those first couple of episodes the calm before the storm that I talked about in my last teaser video into the
Actual explosion of battle itself the thing that's different about this trailer than previous seasons
Is that usually all the Game of Thrones?
Trailers contain footage from pretty much almost the entire season up to the final episode this season
Obviously they want to hold back as much as possible, especially from those last couple of episodes
There's a shot of Davos walking on the battlements probably before the battle happens because it's still so dark behind them
This guy hasn't been lit with red fire
There's a shot of Varys Gilly the women and children hiding in the crypts at Winterfell
Probably during the battle while it's going on just because Varys looks so concerned
So they're actually using the crypts a lot for a lot of different reasons one for the obvious
Reason where Jon Snow goes to talk
So to speak to his father that he thinks Ned Stark and see his mother
Lyanna Stark just a ponder the weight of everything consider what they have to do next the big task ahead of them
So I'll talk about those shots too because there's a couple shots of Jon Snow in the crips with Daenerys
But the Crips themselves would be the safest place for them to go during the battle
There's a shot of Euron bringing back the golden company
Then you actually see the leader of the golden company in his golden armor with very blond Targaryen. Looking hair remember that
It's important because the golden company was founded by a bunch of black buyers
Targaryen bastards that lost the Blackfyre rebellion and were exiled to the east and if you didn't know what their motto is
It's our word is as good as gold
Their claim to fame is is that not only are they really good at their job
They also have never broken a contract with anyone
So you know what?
That means if their word is as good as gold and their Targaryen bastards and you have a Targaryen queen in the north
What a surprise it would be then if they broke their contract to serve Daenerys and turn against Cersei
There's a shot of beric torment and heed from the Nights Watch. Yeah that confirmed alive
We all knew that they were gonna be alive entering what looks like could be the crypts
Winterfell or one of the doors at Winterfell just because they're walking down a flight of stairs if the only places that you walk
Downward in Winterfell, if you're not up at the top of the castle is when you're walking down into the crypts
So that's why I think that it's the crypts
there's also a shot later in the trailer of Jon Snow rushing with a bunch of
Targaryen and stark soldiers at that same door
Then you get the voiceover of Brande
Talking probably to Jon Snow while you get a couple shots of the Dragons flying over Winterfell and Sansa freaking out like oh my god
Those are a couple of dragons. He says everything you did brought you where you are
Now where you belong home based on the context of what he says for a minute
I thought he could be talking about Jamie
But when he says the word home
I think he's talking to Jon Snow because Jon is gonna be so torn about his Targaryen heritage
But Winterfell is the home that he knows Ned Stark is the father that he knew even if he's not his biological father
Love the way they cut in shots of King's Landing and Cersei looking very pleased with herself
While he's giving that voice over to because she's probably seeing you're on ships move into the bay
you see a little boy in winter town just south of Winterfell watching Daenerys his army marched through this is just extra footage from the
Scene of Arya that we got a little while ago
So just more context for what's happening during that from different viewpoints
You get an up-close wide shot of the unsullied Army with Jon Snow and Daenerys marching behind them like we all thought
Then you get your shot of dinner meeting John snow in the crypts at Winterfell
Now you can't really tell which statue he's at, but I'm assuming that in this one
It's relatively early and he's going to Ned Stark statue
because the weight of everything is so
Extreme what they're trying to do save the world from certain death, and he's trying to model himself
His life is an adult and a leader after Ned Stark
So even though Ned Stark died in the first season, he is so important to what's happening this season
There's gonna be so many references to season 1 moments particularly the pilot episode
So what happened in the pilot episode after Robert Baratheon arrived at Winterfell?
They had that funny moment in the courtyard then immediately. He went down to the crypts to visit. Lianna's statue
So this is probably their version of that where they go down and they visit Ned Stark's statue
you get a shot of the forges you see Gendry who's probably
helping them forge weapons and armor because the really cool Easter egg in the background of some of these shots later when you see the
Breastplate is that it's the Targaryen sigil mixed with the stark wolf sigil so you have combo
Breastplates a few people told me that they actually had a wrap party with these combo sigils
So HBO will probably be selling combo merge with this sigil later this year
I don't know what date it'll be available or anything like that because obviously
If they had shown this earlier
It would have been a big spoiler but it makes sense because all these people here aren't part of the unsullied
They're not Dothraki bloodrider x' and those were Daenerys as only soldiers when they arrived at Winterfell
So everybody that's wearing this combo breastplate is probably a northerner you get the voiceover from Jon Snow
Our enemy doesn't tire doesn't stop doesn't feel they give you a shot of grey worm and missandei they're still pushing that ship
Pretty hard grey worm is standing at the front of the army - there's a lot of main characters at the front of the infantry
Line when the army of the Dead arrives they did confirmed they're gonna kill a lot of main characters during those first three episodes
Particularly the big battle episode during episode 3 you get a big wide shot of the dragons flying over the forests in the area around
Winterfell the
corresponding shot in winter town of Arya either looking up at Jon Snow or looking up at the dragons and
Smiling because she's excited now that he's back. There's a shot of Jon Snow and the godswood at the heart tree
This is a very similar scene that you would see Ned Stark
He spent a lot of time in the godswood during season one before
Went down to King's Landing you get a new shot of the Hound in the middle of the battle
You could see all that fire behind him
This will remind you of the infamous Blackwater fight with all the fire behind him where he had one of his most
Famous quotes ever on the TV show you see someone hacking away at White's on top of the battlements at Winterfell
They're using their right hand, so I'm assuming it's not Jamie
It could be the Hound but then you do get a shot of Jamie
Screaming something screaming orders at someone but just remember that Jamie uses his left hand to fight
So if you see someone swinging away with their left hand is probably Jamie you get a shot of Cersei inside a very empty
Iron, throne room meeting what looks like you're on and the leader of the golden company
you see a shot of Cersei drinking wine and it'll remind you because of the way they cut this into the trailer that is just
Like the Blackwater episode where she was hunkered down in maegor's holdfast with Sansa and her ladies-in-waiting just getting drunker and drunker
That's where all the more wine
Memes came from was her
Sassing everyone swinging her wine glass around because she was pretty sure that they might wind up dying that night the other really important thing
About this scene too. Is that because this is probably from the first three episodes
Cersei is really pregnant and guzzling wine Cersei style and being pregnant. Do not mix
She looks like she's been crying a little bit. So this could be after she loses the baby
It's hard to tell Cersei seems like someone who might be willing to drink a little bit of wine while she's pregnant
But he never really can't tell with her. There's a shot of Jamie arriving at Winterfell in the Great Hall
Just giving the same speech. I made a promise I intend to keep it
So this is probably in the first episode sometime. You see someone sharpening their blade
It's hard to tell who it is
But then you see Jon Snow and those soldiers
Marching at the same door that Barrack was going into it could be the crypts at Winterfell
It could just be one of the other entrances to the castle
Then you get a shot of Jon Snow and Daenerys outside way
Beyond the walls at Winterfell walking up to drogon and regal looking like they just finished their lunch
It doesn't look human because the skeletons and the spines here just seem way too large so it could be some animals
But it reminds you of the scene during season four
Where'd Rokon roasted the Shepherd's son?
And you see this charred remains on the ground there, but they seem pretty casual when they're walking up to the Dragons
So I'm assuming that these are just a couple animals and they were just getting something to eat
You get a different shot of Sansa looking very severe on the battlements
This is probably when she notices Daenerys is army marching in through winter town before the draw
Mehgan's fly overhead and freak her out. Then you get a shot of Aria fighting on the battlements with a dragon glass-tipped spear
There's a shot of Daenerys looking like she just got some really really heavy news inside Winterfell
possibly during episode 1 episode 2
Maybe this is after they find out Jon Snow is secretly a Targaryen and she's just like oh Jesus
I don't know how to deal with this
There's a shot of Tyrion looking way way up either at the dragons or Daenerys on one of the dragons you get a different shot
Of drogon in the middle of the night possibly during the battle opening up in flame
You get a slow pan to the front of the army with Brienne and Podrick and Jorah
Probably all the other big main characters that are capable of fighting on the ground
You also reminded about the combo breastplate some of the northerners here of the stark sigil and the Targaryens digital together
Then the camera pans to the left and you see the undead horse's hoof
March in that's not necessarily the night king because remember during the season 7 finale
When the army of the Dead marched up to the wall the night king actually flew in on
Viserion while he was destroying the wall. There was just a regular white Walker. That was leading the army on horseback
So it's probably that same white Walker, but let me know in the comments. What's your favorite part of the trailer?
And if there's any Easter eggs that you saw that I didn't mention in the video and all these shots just write them below in
The comments what'll happen is I'll do a follow-up video for this tomorrow for some of the bigger stuff
Leave your requests in the comments below
And I'll name a giveaway winner when I post that while you wait for everything click here for my teaser video
I talked a little bit about what they've said about that big battle and how it plays out and what's gonna be going on and
Click here for all my other Game of Thrones season 8 trailer and promo videos. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!